[Music]
we all love Shadowhunters but do you
know everything there is to know about
this series wait until you hear some of
the biggest facts including which
Shadowhunter had a thing with Taylor
Swift don't forget to subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up now let's check out the 20 things you
didn't know about Shadowhunters the nays
Clary Fray was first called Valerie
Freyr named after the artist who
designed the rooms then Cassandra found
out her friend was also writing a book
with the main character called Valerie
Clary Fray was actually Cassandra's
editor's choice her full name was going
to be Clarisse but Cassandra then
decided on Clarissa and Max and Isabel
er actually named after her grandparents
while Simon and Mia are named after her
friends and like most writers Cassandra
also chose some of the names out of a
baby name book and Luke Garroway got his
name because Cassandra thought it
sounded like a French word for a
werewolf peers Alec is known as the
brave and fearless one in the story he's
one of the few openly gay Shadowhunters
we absolutely love his story in the
books it's revealed that Alec might
actually have a fear he'd never talked
about before after he was marked with
the fearless room the characters asked
Alec if he has a phobia of any sort and
it turns out that the fearless demon
hunter actually is afraid of something
and no it's not demons alex is actually
afraid of spiders a shadow hunters fan
also asked Cassandra a random fact about
Alec on Twitter she replied that he's
also scared of umbrellas full time rune
cutter did you know that this show had
to hire a full-time Andrew cutter that
has to cut out each individual room the
rooms get applied to the actors but the
behind the scenes stuff requires a lot
of cutting of a large paper with the
prints of all the rooms sounds like an
interesting job but we seriously can't
imagine doing this every single hour of
every day
it might take four minutes to apply each
rune but it takes a lot longer to have
them perfectly cut keep on watching to
hear how many rooms there are in total
ask me anything
don't you just love it when you have a
question about your favorite series but
it just so happens you can just go
online and ask the writer that's
luckily what you can do if you love
Shadowhunters along with a frequently
asked question section on her website
Cassandra Clare is extremely active on
Tumblr and Twitter she frequently
replies to her fans and has in-depth
discussions about some of your favorite
characters she also has educational
resources for students writing an essay
or people who actually want to become
writers so if you have a burning
question for Cassandra
you know where to go to get the answer
Serafina Serafina was the grandmother of
Clary Fairchild featured in the city of
lost souls book she passed away after
suffering from a heart attack but
Clary's dad had it his way and if he'd
actually known he had a daughter at the
time he wouldn't name her Clarissa aka
Clary
in fact he often expressed his
disapproval of the name he'd name her
after his own mother
so Clary could potentially have a
completely different name not only
because of the writer herself but also
because of another book character to be
honest the name Serafina actually suits
Clary it's definitely a powerful name
but let's be honest there's also nothing
wrong with Clarisse full name Clarissa
Clary sage did you know that the age of
the characters in the books is actually
a bit different than the age in the show
the show seemed to have aged up the
characters the books took place in 2007
Clary was born in 1991 which made her 16
years old in the very first book called
City of Bones and while the characters
of the show did actually aged up with
the story we know Clary was 18 in the
beginning of the series so how come she
didn't have the same age on the show are
the themes of the show too serious
sixteen-year-old modeling career
Shadowhunters has an amazing cast but
did you know that there are several
actors who've only had very little
acting roles prior to their appearance
on the show
for example Emeraude Tobia had a role in
a telenovela and a leading role in
tattooed love but before she made her
way on the TV screens
she was actually a model she was in
several beauty pageants as a teenager
and then started her modeling career
before diving into acting though despite
her early modeling career we hope that
she never leaves the acting world
football player we're telling you this
show is living proof that talented
actors come from all sorts of
backgrounds who would have thought that
a football player would become a
werewolf in Shadowhunters yep Luke
Garroway aka Isaiah Mustafa actually
tried out for NFL teams and got signed
to the practice squad he also attended
the Seattle Seahawks training camp
Isaiah also wanted to be a teacher but
decided to pursue an acting career
instead we're pretty sure his life would
have been completely different if he
actually ended up playing for Seattle
Seahawks Old Spice commercials speaking
of Isaiah here's an interesting fact if
Luke Garroway space looked familiar but
you can't remember where you saw him
before this might help refresh your
memory remember those old school Old
Spice commercials from 2010
Isaiah actually got his first glimpse of
Fame after he was featured in the the
man your man could smell like commercial
the hilarious commercial showed Isaiah
coming out of the shower telling the
ladies that although their man might not
look like him he could smell like him if
you used Old Spice yep that's the same
guy that you see on Shadowhunters
tattoos some actors are incredibly
appreciative of the roles that open
doors to new projects and since most
actors from the show started out in very
humble roles they wanted to make their
time on Shadowhunters
really memorable so memorable they
actually got a tattoo of the angelic
room both Kathryn McNamara and Dominic
Sherwood have a small angelic rune
tattoo Dominic's is on his calves and
Catherine's is on the side of her heal
now that is some true dedication to a
series and an awesome way to never
forget a life-changing experience
dedicated fan base there's a reason why
the Shadowhunters books were turned into
a series this series have an incredibly
dedicated fan base the first season of
Hunter's averaged at almost 1 million
viewers aged between 18 and all the way
up to 49 the second seasons average was
0.6 million but it's safe to say that
many people were just as excited to read
the books the show has a lot of fans
that write their own fan fictions as
well as those that submit fan art but
more about that in just a bit
Cassandra's approval the changes you see
on the show were all approved by
Cassandra who actually visited the set
for the first time in July 2016 for
Alberto Rosen's aka Simon this has been
an honoring experience as he said he was
quite a fanboy cassandra said she's
extremely happy with the choices the
show was made even though they might
have been slightly different from the
books while sometimes the writers of the
books really don't like the way the
producers are turning their show to life
this wasn't the case for Cassandra she
encouraged the cast to tell the story in
a new way and stop worrying about
changing the characters the Shadowhunter
quality speaking of character change
have you noticed that all Shadowhunters
have the most exceptional hair ever
it always looks immaculate no matter
what they do according to Matthew
daddario aka Alec Lightwood this is a
Shadowhunter quality he said that the
elite force of fighting demons just
needs to have fantastic hair and
apparently this is something they talked
about on the set going into battle and
coming out of it with immaculate hair is
apparently just an added bonus to being
a Shadowhunter
we wonder if this also works on rolling
out of the bed because if so we'd like
to sign up to be shadow hunters to the
title we already talked about the fact
that most of the names have been
inspired by actual people but you know
where the name shadow hunters came from
in one of her tweets Cassandra revealed
that her book editor was the one that
actually came up with the term she
didn't say what she called the shadow
hunters before but this just proves how
important it is to get a second opinion
on your work who knows your editor might
actually coin a term that will turn into
something much bigger than just one book
hi-five Cassandra's editor more
characters if you love shadow hunters
but want to see more characters you
absolutely have to check out the books
they feature one of our favorite
characters ever called Cristina the copy
addicted shadow hunter speaks seven
languages and she's
just simply awesome in the books she's
also a character with strong religious
beliefs and extremely nice to just about
anyone seriously we still wonder why she
wasn't chosen for the TV show a
Shadowhunter addicted coffee yes please
some of the TV characters are also
largely different from the books so if
you want to see them in a different way
head to the library No Limit wardrobe
Magnus Bane was the one Shadowhunters
character that was actually based on
Wardrobe alone you probably already know
that his wardrobe is absolutely
exceptional and has no limits his
costume designers said that his fashion
has no boundaries when harry comes in
for a fitting the designers just start
with a base piece and then experiment
with some of the craziest details ever
and hey it definitely did the job it was
also revealed that the makeup team
applies the glitter by hand it turns out
that working on the Shadowhunter set is
extremely time-consuming shades of red
although Cassandra did tell the team
that they can recreate the shadows
hunter world in whatever way they want
the producer still wanted to make sure
to get a couple of things right Clary's
red hair has been a huge debate for fans
that came completely enchanted by
Clara's red hair in the books the show's
hairstyle explained that it took a lot
and we mean a lot of tries to get that
perfect shade of red for Clara's hair
they decided to go with a natural ginger
hair to add a warmer red tone that
wouldn't appear as fake and if you ask
us it worked
fan art the show really takes into
consideration what fans think or what to
see from it which to be honest is pretty
awesome because we all know that there
are people out there who absolutely
dislike certain TV show adaptations so
in order to find the perfect shade of
red for Clara's hair and capture some of
the other looks the team actually went
on tumblr they printed out the fan art
they thought best emulated the
characters unique features it's pretty
awesome that the team actually got
inspired by fan art especially since
fans spent hours on hours illustrating
some of the most impressive pieces ever
79 rooms so how many rooms are there in
total we all know the Shadowhunters have
the marks of Raziel as runic language
which grabs powers beyond mundanes the
runes are applied directly to the bodies
of Shadowhunters there are 77 rooms out
there
in total but in order to make sure the
show is different from the books the
team added two new rooms so there are 79
rooms in total the new rooms added are
the site in the dark one and the
shape-shifting room think about the room
cutting that includes for the people
that have to do this as their full-time
job Taylor Swift association
Dominic Sherwood aka Jays has actually
appeared in Taylor Swift's music video
for the song style back in 2015
yep that's right as of April two
thousand eighteen more than half a
billion people saw the music video but
not a lot of them knew that the man with
the daydream look in his eyes is
actually Jase Taylor probably didn't
write that song about him bet hey we'll
take it who would have thought that Jase
the expert shadow hunter was once
someone Taylor Swift almost kissed
seriously watch the video if you haven't
seen it yet he does an absolutely
amazing job looking all dreamy
he really does have that James Dean
daydream look in his eyes doesn't he
good job dumb and that's all for our
video let us know what you think in the
comments thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]